anybody that's commenting on my comments
in a mean way or saying something
negative or saying something nasty I
know that that person must be in pain or
must not be very happy because I know a
lot of happy and successful people and I
know that not one of them would ever
even dare to just go on the internet and
comment negatively or something mean on
somebody's post my relationship with
that is understand that this is part of
the game and try as hard as I possibly
can to not let it affect me in a
negative way or not keep me from showing
up because for every single person
that's on there talking smack there's
probably at least least 20 30 40 50
other people that really liked that post
that really got a lot out of it and
maybe for some of those people it helped
them in a way that I don't even know